let's talk about all of these foreign
policy challenges with Brian Hook senior
policy adviser to the Secretary of State
he joins us tonight from Washington
Brian thanks for being here thanks Brian
good to be with you let's start with
Iran and what Secretary Pompeo said
today how realistic does the secretary
does the State Department does the
administration believe that these 12
stipulations will actually be agreed to
eventually by Iran the list of
requirements that secretary Pompeo
called out today in this speech on Iran
is a very reasonable and realistic list
in fact if you go through the list
it focuses on things like Iran's nuclear
weapons program its support for
terrorism its Foreign Wars that it funds
around the Middle East its violation of
Human Rights
all of these are positions that the
United States and its European allies
have held at one time or another and so
this is the kind of new approach that we
are taking to create a new security
architecture in the context of the
totality of Iran's threats you know
here's someone who negotiated before
former ambassador Wendy Sherman talking
about this I think that Pompeo gave us a
wish list today and it's a wish list
probably everybody could agree to but
you can't get it all at once because
then you're negotiating against yourself
as one is traded off against the other
you respond to that
well I think that's a very defeatist
attitude and I think that when it comes
to addressing the full range of Iranian
threats we do need to take a
comprehensive and very ambitious
approach in the speech the Secretary of
Pompeo delivered today does exactly that
yeah on the tweets coming from the
Iranians at the end of it it references
that Iran is still working with European
partners to continue the jcpoa the Iran
nuclear agreement that the u.s. pulled
out of how much of a problem is that
going forward and how do you calculate
that in I think that the United States
and its European allies
a very similar threat assessment and
we've been working with them over the
last few months to address the
deficiencies of the Iran nuclear deal
we also made progress on all of the
malign activities that fall outside of
just the nuclear program and I think a
lot of that foundational work can be
built upon but we're not just limiting
our work to the European allies
secretary Pompeo has invited nations
from around the world that share his
concerns to join us in this diplomatic
effort we are looking to work with
nations who are sick and tired of Iran's
quest for a nuclear weapon for who are
tired of Iran's terrorism for its
funding and fueling sectarian violence
for violating human rights we've set
forth a very ambitious agenda that we
think much of the world can get behind I
want to touch on two other quick things
but finally on Iran what do you say to
critics who look at this and say this
really isn't about another deal it's
about regime change or the possibility
of regime change the only thing that
we'd like to see is a change in the
behavior of the Iranian regime and it's
not just the United States it's the
Iranian people the longest suffering
victims of the Iranian regime or the
Iranian people and they are looking for
a better life and a better future
they've had protests where they've
expressed this they would like to have
better better economics they would
they're tired of their government
funding Foreign Wars and robbing from
the Iranian economy to sow instability
across the Middle East and so we think
that we've set forth the kind of
positive vision that could actually
change relations with Iran the secretary
put on the table that if Iran is ready
to change its behavior we're ready to
talk about a range of benefits including
full diplomatic ties welcoming Iran into
the global economy and other things that
would materially improve the lives of
the Iranian people well it's a similar
negotiation with North Korea as we sit
here today the
what do you think the likelihood is that
the June 12th summit moves forward
between President Trump and Kim jong-il
well secretary Pompeo has now made two
trips to North Korea to try to set the
table for a successful meeting in
Singapore on June 12th these sorts of
things take twists and turns that's not
uncommon with North Korea and so all we
can do is try to be in a state of
readiness and to do what we can so that
we can have a very good discussion about
as president Trump has talked about a
very bright future for the North Korean
people if there is if the regime is
willing to denuclearize and last thing
for the people up on Capitol Hill people
who are skeptical of how this is all
coming together what do you tell them
that the administration the president is
not going to give the store away or is
not going to get played by either in
North Korea or China in negotiations
ongoing I think the president is coming
in from a position of great strength he
has assembled the largest sanctions
campaign against North Korea in history
and so he's in a very good position
whether the talks happen or not whether
the talks go well or poorly the global
maximum pressure campaign is going to
continue until we achieve our national
security objectives
Brian Hooke director of policy of the
State Department
thanks for being here love to have you
back okay thanks Brett